you know we we we talked about had to
get jez's input on that while we got him
we gonna get into these topics um Lord
adct there's a game that came out
Spider-Man 2 dropped a lot of
Impressions I know you are probably one
of the few people that I seen besides
bit Cloud after you that beat the game
already so um yeah give us your thoughts
where do you where does it land for you
you know talk talk to us you know well
Spider-Man 2 is out here in these
streets uh let me uh oh oh oh chill CH
y you you scar of me bro what's going on
why we got the chill why you looking at
the camera uhoh what's going on like
like a manscape adendum coming yeah like
ho addicts let's go yeah so I did beat
the game uh I don't know if you have
like a list of questions that you want
to ask me I mean f for me I my whole
thing is I probably got the least hours
out of everybody here you know what I'm
saying but you know I I'll just jump in
What m presss and then ask you a few
questions to build off that um you know
the game looked gorgeous um you know for
me it was uh 4K HDR I was able to turn
the vrr that 120 HZ is moving he's
zipping around this the city felt the
combat was fast-paced um as far as U one
of my favorite skills like the momentum
swinging when you got that with for both
they got the skill tree for both and
then um the gadget with do you know I
could never get the loop-de-loop thing
to work oh you get loop loop I tried so
many times maybe I'm doing something
wrong yeah or maybe it's bugged because
at this point I don't know what is what
but I would try CU it it literally just
says hold R2 when you're when when yeah
when you're when you're going down and
every time he just strings up like it
just he never does the full loop to Loop
yeah for me it was acrobatic the Rhythm
the parrying the special moves it was a
nice flow to it Kings killing me with
that with that Spiderman we G to get to
you King but um the thing I do want to
ask also cuz I so far I probably got
like five six hours I was playing Tekken
this weekend I'm just going to be honest
but um the thing I will say this solve
still don't like his voice miles's voice
I hate miles's voice but I gotta be
honest at first I didn't know how to
take the bug situation you know what I'm
saying and that's why I want to ask you
ad it's like did you come across any
bugs
bro all right I'm not you didn't even
play that long you bro that's yet all
right I can't so I can't spoil the I
should spoil the name of the first boss
no don't spoil any of it I will say
don't so I won't all I will say the
first boss
encounter that you
encounter it was a lot of swinging
involved just to clarify we're talking
about the tutorial boss right no I
believe so yeah Bas I the start of the
game whatever the start of the game
whatever is the first major boss that
you
fight it there's a sequence of swinging
and then you have to press an input like
a a triangle or whatever whatever and
then that proceeds and then you knock
things down as it was going it stopped
recognizing the triangle input and the
boss had this much energy left and I'm
like I'm doing it multiple time like
what is going on it was so bad The Game
Wouldn't progress I had to die and then
reload the save and then it worked and
I'm just like the game progression I'm
like yo what what's up with that of
course there's going to be little
glitches here and there and the last
point I saiding I'll give it to you adct
cuz I'm curious about your experience is
is the there was a I'm trying not to
spoil there's a stealth section in a
school and I was in this
section and yeah you got to you got to
string somebody up and I had to get to
this point and the game is telling me L2
string up or whatever right wouldn't
string up right yeah and I'm like bro
I'm I'm sitting there like what is going
on again I have to pause to get Kill by
myself get spotted or whatever and
actually load the last checkpoint and
then it worked so my issue this is so
early I am surprised that it I would I I
thought it was going to be graphical
bugs or something that that's not like
that com in the game but game
progression bugs really bother me I was
get frustrated I was surprised to see
that happen and I do want to shout out
um ACG who put out a statement in
reference to the bugs he's encountered
it feels it seems like there's a there
was a day one patch that may have made
things worse I don't know if there was
just different from the reviewers and
shout out to John lindman who um jez
Cordon had on the Xbox 2 recently with
with ran you know he confirmed it he was
like it he wonder if the patch messes up
cuz now he's in encountering all these
bugs so adct I'm going to give it to you
or give it to y'all whoever played I
definitely experienced it yeah it's a
very buggy game um my PlayStation soft
crash three times oh where it it would
do that it would do that like a little
loading thing you we want to tell
PlayStation is that okay with you like I
had that happened three times you said
it crashed three times yeah well it
didn't like the whole PlayStation crash
it just booted back to the menu three
times oh it just kicked you out just I
had
multiple uh multiple menu cues where
like Cog was saying you click something
and it I head to the point where I was
fighting in a certain Coliseum thing and
it was like yo push this button and this
button and and I had to keep it felt
like to me if I didn't press and I kept
dying so I had to like I I would sit
there I I would fight these
individuals and then if I died and I
went back to it it might it glitched
again so I was literally cting the
restart the restart um check point yeah
four or five times to get one run
through and then if I died I'd have to
reset it another four or five times to
get another run through uh because what
was going on is it was like glitching it
wasn't
registering that the buttons worked yes
and and it's just like then I had a time
uh there's like a like and people said I
did the side mission I didn't do the
activities like the uh you know the pr
uh the prowler stuff I didn't do none of
that stuff like the little I call it
their version of book
bags um and the funny thing is they they
you don't need none of that to be honest
with you because okay maybe in
spectacular I see like Persona playing
on spectacular even smooth for some
reason is playing on spectacular
so they they kind of like put a lot of
that with like the hero points and stuff
where you can actually add on to your
stuff tell me how I upgraded two natural
stats
too and tell me
how I didn't have much issues in this
game like like I would say the
difficulty of this game
is yeah it's difficulty with them dogs
yeah I I would say that um the game the
game difficulty is very low it is it's
very low uh I was very I was a little
bit disappointed with that I personally
felt like because they took away like
the little Gadget well now everything's
like uh it's like L1 L1 R11 which is a
way better system I like it yeah I like
way better system and but the problem is
is when you make stuff simpler it's
easier in the actual game like I I was
getting to the point where nothing was
touching me nothing nothing and then
there's stuff that go on in the future
that nothing really ain't touching me
like and you know because I I talked to
King I was like King I thought I knew a
little bit about
Spiderman stuff was happening that's
like did Insomniac do this or is this a
real person I was Googling them
get contact King for the L one thing I
want to really you know I I want to
really give a shout out to them they
really captured Peter with the simu suit
on because you you know obviously we've
seen him in it in the trailers where you
he he his personality changes like like
it's just how you would expect it to be
and they did a really good job right it
um I beat it in like probably 12 13
hours like I said I none of the you know
uh I didn't do most of the activity
stuff I didn't care to be honest with
you they they tied it to it's like I
said they tied at to Stats you can get
your HP up your focus up I I focused all
on the focus thing because to me I can
help myself with Focus why why anything
else so you did but did you as far as
did you level up because you know you
got miles and skill Tre then you got
Peter and then you got the combination
of both I loved how they did that I like
how they did that that was dope do I'm
going to be real with you you don't need
none of that either really like for the
most part now all that makes the game
significantly easier but just how they
they do the you know the the countering
system the new Parry system that's all
you really need that Parry is crazy you
could probably beat this game now
obviously I did update all that stuff I
updated all the skills but you could
realistically easily beat this game
which is the parry and the and the
dodging what about what about the the um
the fly with the suit with the Glide now
how you like like 100% better GL is fire
I think I'd have collected book bags if
it was the
M you wasn't taking photos you for the
dud you wasn't no speaking of the photos
the very first time you did the photo
thing I like because they're like oh get
on top of a building and take a picture
I'm sure you guys know it's at the very
beginning of the game tell me how I I
lagged through the building and I was in
the building on the bottom of the
building and I can still bring up the
picture but when I supposed to be taking
the pictures above me so I had to reload
the checkpoint that was the first issue
I had I it's like I said I had um
multiple audio uh and glitches yeah it
it wasn't bad audio it just like buzzing
like like certain like key effects like
a
bug no it it would be like let's say
let's say the the electricity sound
sometimes that would stay a little
longer than it should have yeah and then
I had um is Electro
here I I I had a lot of like clipping in
certain areas there uh now obviously
people say well addict you know they
they
were you know there's a lot of people
you can actually go in the photo mode
and look like there's clipping but no
there's actual clipping in the game like
there's no denying that apparently if
you take I saw someone on Twitter and
you can't Photoshop this this was live
they were they were on the bike and they
were clipping through the
every every NPC on the sidewalk so it's
like the game was like take this area
this middle area but if you go on the
left or right none of the NPCs are
registering you're on a bicycle oh I
know you're talking about yeah I know
which part you're talking okay okay yeah
I did I didn't challenge the game that
way but I heard people did yeah here's
the thing besides the photo mode thing
because that's you you should be ashamed
of yourself besides that people are say
well
addict some of these xbots are are
they're they're they're trying to break
the
game okay theyve paid x amount of
dollars to try to break the game you
know what shouldn't happen the game
should
break you know in a little stuff like
falling through the map I don't care
what people try you shouldn't fall
through the
map and then people are sitting there
and they're like they're like oh these
are just small no the there is multiple
anytime time you have to reload a
checkpoint that's a game breaking that's
what I was about to ask you because
that's what surprised me I didn't I was
explicit clipping happens you know your
feet is uneven on the surface no not you
not you I'm no no I I was say that's
what I saying I didn't say nothing about
that and the funny thing is just like
none of that bothered me you know you
know why I I think that they got a huge
pass on this because their checkpoint
system is
extremely easy they have check for
everything so realistically if you have
a glitch that happens you have to uh
reload the last checkpoint it's probably
going to be two minutes back yeah no
absolutely but I'm glad you said I'm
glad you mentioned that I you had the
table which was a game progression bug
where you literally cannot go for it
because of whatever is not registering
or whatever but I'm glad but I know we
talked about Buzz last thing I want to
say before we move on is just the you
beat it bro like you beat it right so
like gameplay experence like is it one
of the top joints ever is this
PlayStation's best exclusive me to me
it's the best PlayStation 5
game that's CRA even even though the
bugs and stuff annoyed me I there was a
one time even even when I was in that
part where I had to probably spent an
hour reloading checkpoints just to fight
this one particular fight I was like
let's do it I really enjoyed it and you
know I'm a huge person on boss fights I
was very critical of the boss fights and
and Spider-Man one it it's like they
listened to exactly what I thought like
CU cuz the the boss fights in this game
completely on a different level multiple
areas sometimes you chasing them
sometimes you not CH they're changing
the the the ways you fight them the
change of the conditions you fight them
like phenomenal boss fights and
especially the last boss fight I'm not
going to say what it is who it is or
anything that is some of the best like
what's the the word you use when you
when you determine how a fight is done
uh mechanics or um no uh people do it in
like actual fight fights like fight
choreography choreography of that fight
is intense it kept me all my the the
edge of my seat the whole time I I love
like the the Bantry between people is
just insane in this game give it and
then when you add like uh I didn't I
knew here's the thing I didn't know
because obviously it's not a spoiler
Venoms in the game right I didn't know
that when you put that suit on it
changed you to that degree I just
thought made you more aggressive I
didn't know it changes your personality
pretty much symbiot baby yeah symbiot
takes over you that that is the
singlehandedly best narrative thing when
you add that symbiot in this giant
mixing pool known as
Spiderman I feel like the relationship
between Peter and miles is
phenomenal you know this this is so what
would you give it though yeah what's the
score I I want to give it a nine but
those is man I got to give it a hate and
it's just like the game's that good it
really is it's you know even all these
issues I wouldn't even say wait for a
day one patch just hit that re restart
checkpoint over and
over it's just like it's a good game it
really is it's F so the person that
advocates for people taking time with
broken games don't put them games out uh
bugs and stuff like that you said just
buy the game and if you coun to the bug
just go back to the checkpoint I get it
I get it I have an issue with how the
developers and stuff are handling it uh
apparently they they they put the wrong
flag in the game as well oh sof can we
get the resident the developers are are
taking ownership they're taking
accountability that's my issue talking
about the Cuban flag yeah they had the
Cuban flag that's the Lord Lord Puerto
Rico do we see cuz I what I I initially
I looked at it quickly and I just wanted
to make sure that they they hadn't put
the old Puerto Ric flag which uh the
blue part of the flag is lighter than
what it is now they changed it to make
it more more akin to the the the colors
of the United States flag but no this is
this is the Cuban
flag this is the Cuban flag yeah that
that is egregious that is egregious but
quality control is key over there yeah
something that is egregious something's
going on and it's just like yeah yeah
room is burning now Sonia has responded
and said that they're going to fix it
but yeah that that especially with mil's
background
fromto and them not having made that
type of mistake in his game um and then
being so good about you know
authenticity when it came to especially
Christmas time like Christmas time you
get Christmas time Puerto Rican stuff
wrong they're GNA be riots in the street
and they they kind of got it right so um
yeah I mean I
gu but we don't got we don't got the
flag right they got pastelis they got P
they got it all you know uh they had
whole conversations in Spanish but
couldn't get the flag right yeah
hold on now I'm open it up to Sol it
King but I got it CU I know je you know
resident Xbox but it's it's playing
Spider-Man 2 something you would be
interested in it's something that you
got your eye I know you love the MCU you
love Marvel Lord these are your favorite
type of
games n I'm I'm just not a superhero guy
man like I I I sort of have some passing
interest in Batman and and DC but like
Marvel is just it's way too colorful
and I love his disc I want to SP I want
I want a spawn game or a Judge Dread
game on on that sort of quality yeah I
don't know I don't know I'm kind of emo
I guess but um I but like looking at it
from the outside um you know and someone
who Rel you know I Sunset Overdrive was
the first ever AAA game that I reviewed
the first ever one that I had a review
code for like God God knows how long ago
this was now like this is this is before
I was like professional or whatever like
reviewed it on my own blog MH um so in
somniac is kind of special to me in a
sort of weird way yes um but um so like
looking at from the outside and seeing
like the technical the technical
capability of the studio and how they've
sort
of
um I people say they car they've been
carrying Sony right MH and they're kind
of like they've been so consistent with
their delivery of games and and high
quality games and critically acclaimed
games so it's kind of impressive looking
for the outside doesn't appeal to me
personally I'm not going to run out and
buy a PS5 for it um but uh yeah I'm glad
that people are enjoying it I guess I do
have one more question for you
specifically I know you know this is not
your your style of game but I guess the
question since we're on the subject of
bugs and you know I see where King is
about to go I think but I want to asked
you this one just like what do you feel
about you know some some Xbox fans felt
upset that uh Starfield was uh really
penalized for their bugs at launch and
now with affecting the Metacritic store
whereas you know Spider-Man it's coming
out now that there are you know a lot of
technical issues and bugs with it you
know I'm not going to go down the media
bias path but what do you think about
I'm not going to go down the media bu
path but but I have to ask you what do
you think about bugs affecting review
score in general you know work you
window Central you you you cover a lot
of games like how much does that factor
into for your reviews you're talking to
a guy who gave cyong 10 out of 10 at
launch so you know
wow you were play a PC version you was
good yeah I was definitely on the PC
version but even the PC version had like
some bugs and quirks like I remember
when I was reviewing it there was there
was a sequence where like a pretty
emotional sequence where the the
character model had come out of syn with
the camera so like the the character
model was sort of like the camera was
moving but the car the character kept
sliding out of shot and I was like man
that really sucks because it's like you
know it's it's emotional impact moment
but like that's the only bug that I can
remember from reviewing cyber Punk on on
my PC you know but like there was a
there was a naivity with me where I was
kind of like man it's so weird they
wouldn't give us an Xbox review code I'm
sure it's fine
though and now I've now I've learned my
lesson you know so it's like when when
the devs insist on a PC version and they
they like the the Xbox codes will come
at launch then it's kind of like okay
there's something wrong with the console
version so there was a teachable there
was a teachable moment for me but some
reviewers are more sensitive to that
thing than others I personally don't
really care that much about bugs you
know unless it's something like constant
crashing or you know um just glitches
that constantly interfere with with game
playay and stuff the problem like I
think it was it was Paul tassy from
Forbes put out an article recently where
it was like social media really blows
bugs out of proportion cuz people people
take the little clips and um and they're
just like and it it presents the whole
game in that frame you know that frame
and it could be like there it could be
like that you've had a 20 20 30 hour
long experience and maybe maybe
experience two two bugs that were worth
clipping to put on Twitter or something
and that was my experience with cyber
Punk on PC like I played the game for 30
hours through to review and then I maybe
had like two major issues with the game
and I I remember this other issue where
like sometimes cars would clip through
the floor and there was another issue
where sometimes uh guns would float in
the air after You' killed an enemy like
the gun hadn't properly R to the fact
that it was no longer being held by an
NPC and it wouldn't hit the ground right
so like and it was just like those
things didn't bother me that much and
maybe they bother some reviews more than
others or some Gamers more than others
but I don't really care about bugs you
know and things can be fixed and
Polished and patched and stuff and it's
like is the underlying is the underlying
ISS is the
underlying um is the underlying game you
know does it work is it playable is it
functional you know and definitely it's
obviously preferable if you know the the
game you're paying $70 for is completely
10 out of 10 polish true mine but his
game's get increasingly more complex and
our expectations grow in terms of you
know complex it and and overlapping
systems and that kind of thing bugs and
[__] happens occasionally like fair I
just think I just think it's like you
know I've got bigger problems I give
I've got bigger problems to worry about
than like a floating gun or or an NPC
getting stuck in a lamp poost or
something get get some real problems get
some real problems fair enough that's
where you at that's where you at Lord
solve your experience in Spider-Man 2
how we feeling Impressions where you at
um yeah so I have maybe like five or six
hours in um and I downloaded it right at
midnight um and I didn't play I I got up
early to play a little bit right so uh
different to uh re Spider-Man remastered
and Miles Morales I played those those
two on my previous television so I
played them in R tracing uh performance
mode gotcha so here I was like you know
what got the new TV let me try out the
Fidelity mode in conjunction with vrr
and the 100 20 HZ mode on at the same
time and from the O the onset of the
game like at the outset it was it was
clippy it was weird it was bugging out
so I was like all right let me turn off
this vrr and just leave it 120 and see
if that runs fine and that fixed it so I
I fixed it and I did like the that first
boss battle I actually left it in the
middle of the first boss battle and I
didn't come back to it until last night
when I come back to it last night I had
to go do a restart because apparently
something was some kind of patch or
something was downloaded and now the vrr
was fixed and I had I could run it in
Fidelity mode with vrr full on on vrr I
think on automatic or something like
that or smooth or something like that
smooth automatic with the 120 yeah right
and I had the 120 on as well and it was
smooth as butter it was so beautiful um
so I'm gonna be frank I didn't have a
lot of the glitches that people are
talking about only play like five or six
hours but I haven't had those issues the
only thing that I that for me happened
was I had one or two little um audio
glitches where where the like background
music was garbled a little bit then it
fixed itself and then another thing that
I had was when I like to run up the
buildings run up the buildings and the
top of the building at the top of the
building hit X and shoot myself off and
continue my momentum so for a little
while there the X prompt wasn't coming
up and it wasn't well when I got to the
top of the building he would just run up
to the top of the building and just not
and not sling himself over um and I was
like wow why is it not is not reacting
but then after a while that also sort of
fixed itself it happened a couple of
times and it fixed itself and then since
then haven't really had anything major
in terms of glitches just the idea that
sometimes when I you know when you hit
the two um trigger buttons to try to uh
ZIP to a point every now and again he
won't zip he won't land on the point per
se he he'll get there and do that same
thing where he's kind of floating in
place and just drops down right um and
then when you compare that to the to
remaster remaster it off the bat to me
was like this this perfect feeling sort
of like none of that none of that was
broken really um so that honestly the
only thing in terms of bugs and glitches
that has affected me so far um in terms
of what I feel about the game the game
is gorgeous game is beautiful the game
is beautiful aesthetically playing it on
that Fidelity mode um seeing you know
the the the added sort of you know we
pay attention to those little things so
like the added Fidelity to the ray Trace
uh sort of Reflections and shadows uh
really makes a difference although I
haven't I like I said I played R tracing
performance before and before that
difference wasn't Stark I haven't even
gone to it yet I'm going to try it but I
haven't gone to it because the Fidelity
mode has been so good um the density of
just the people in the city walking down
um just going down one thing that that
was weird to me is that he doesn't have
a walk animation now it's like a creep
animation
he this is weird I'm like where the walk
animation he's just creeping around like
the people on the ground it was very
weird little things like that um but
overall the game is just gorgeous um the
addition of Brooklyn and Queens Que in
the building the addition of the wings
like the the city feels so much more
alive they they really did a great job
with that um let me address something
real quick in the chat so people sitting
there saying what where was this energy
with cyber punk where was this energy
with with uh Lords of the Fallen those
games were genuinely broken there's
difference between a game having bugs
and being an inconvenience and a game
not functioning correctly stop acting
like they're the same CU you guys were
willing to be oh where was that energy
for Starfield then because there were
bugs in Starfield but I told you guys I
educated and said these are the issues I
had but there has been patches that is
put out but I would still recommend
starf where was that energy Chad yeah
where was that energy saying where's
that energy I love y'all but if y'all
here just to the just to hate for the
sake of hating go go go play a game just
just wait for K just wait for K
opportunity to do your
D great for King he got no wor the devil
gonna get his
D continue so
um so yeah so the game is a gorgeous
game and I to me the things that they've
done to to sort of elevate the city and
make it feel more alive is great the um
I found that I love mil
as a character I've said it before I'm
not a fan of his voice me too he he
doesn't sound like a New Yorker he
sounds like a Cali kid like K and and
and I I love the I love the per apart
from How The Voice Sounds the
performance is good I just don't like
the tone he does not sound like a New
Yorker that's just my beef with him um
but overall like move set uh the things
he can do in conjunction with Peter I
think is very cool although for me it's
like I get it putting them together in
one game but I it feels like to me this
is a Peter story right I want I want to
see how they incorporate miles into the
story right it's very interesting to me
but at the same time the Symbiote story
whatever that's a Peter story to me so
I'm like I'm kind of sticking to to
Peter in that regard um but miles's move
set is super you know it's it's super
fun and interesting his act you know his
his athleticism and how acrobatic he is
in conjunction with like the the Venom
powers make super fun to use
um the things that they've done to
combat to simplify to addex point to me
I really enjoyed that the fact that
everything is on Face buttons now you
just press R1 L1 and it happens very
quickly um yeah I mean everything
they've done to combat just beautiful
like the the the additional sort of
finishing moves and things like that um
the way that they kind of you know how
these games the sequels will tell you
like oh you lost all your powers you got
to start all over again it's kind of
like that but it doesn't feel that way
like you the in joint Powers you see
that there's certain powers that were in
the skill tree beforehand that it's like
oh okay I did this before whatever but
they've added stuff as well so it kind
of feels like at the end of it if once
you get everything out it might be a
little overwhelming to pick certain
things that you like and dislike but
again the first one was real good at you
kind of picking the way you play as
Spider-Man right your your different
moves and stuff like that the different
gadgets that you employ makes each
person's gameplay style a little bit
different so I enjoyed that um in terms
of story so far I think
it's what they try to do and I I don't
know that I dislike it at all like there
there are quiet moments that they create
in their that uh their cinematic moments
that have gameplay interspersed in them
whether like flashback moments or stuff
like that that what they're trying to do
is just give you a sort of backstory on
these characters their relationships and
things like that and I think for the
most part it works because the thing
about it like for me like in comics like
you read a comic Comics are these
ongoing have been going on forever right
but at the same time they're not a novel
right a novel is is is meant to give you
every little detail in something and and
then you know when you when you take
that novelization and turn it into a
game or a movie you have to kind of
Whittle that down a little bit so here
they're like okay we're going to fill in
these blanks in a way it's kind of my
criticism of the first uh games with the
you know like the stealth part portions
with like MJ or stuff that I didn't like
those things I didn't like but these
particular instances I'm talking about
about where it's more narrative driven
and trying to show you relationships to
me I thought they worked I thought the
little gameplay stuff interspersed
within them worked just to give context
for where these characters have been
together where they're going um kind of
who they are as people and how they are
you know if you're a fan of these
characters in different iterations how
they're different in this Insomniac
version so I thought that was cool
there's some weird little gameplay
things that they Implement that kind of
feel like one-offs yeah like there
there's like a a a basketball shooting
mechanic did you make your shot did you
did you beat your Miss see at first I
was like do I even try to and I realize
I can control it and then I was like
wait a minute I can control it so I I
only hit one
basket yeah I was
like now I'm like damn I want to know if
I made it and beat him if I get a trophy
for that yeah good so right and that
might be a trophy or something that you
go back to I beat them you don't get no
trophy you don't get no trophy thank you
King for for clarifying very quickly
but just cool stuff like uh the the fall
damage I don't know if any of yall got
the Splat um the Splat Trophy and cuz I
went to the highest building I could
find and just jumped off and then did
the dive right down and uh yeah it was
it was funny because you just kind of
Crash um but I enjoyed it I'm enjoying
it so far uh I'm excited to see where
they go with with you know with Craven
and with Venom and and that
um I I I think it's a great game I think
it's a great game and I have had the
issues that other people have had so and
that happens right sometimes people's uh
you know uh experiences with the game
just differ so much and it's like what
the heck happened you know people talk
about crashing to desktop you know
crashing to the the home screen and
stuff like that so I'm enjoying what
I've seen so far uh I'm interested to
you know H shout out to hog hog had put
out you know kind of a little statement
on Twitter talking about how he feels
like the storytelling and and how Sony
games uh approach to narrative narrative
is sort of overindulgent and Bloated and
it instead of it it shows you instead of
just having you infer things you know it
kind of treats Their audience maybe like
they're a little dumb that have they
have to they have to expound on every
single little emotional beat
and I get it at the same time this isn't
like it does the storytelling I don't
think is as refined as maybe a Last of
Us or that because it is Spider-Man it
is does have to be more broadly
appealing I think so I get it when they
sort of maybe treat you like you're a
little dumb or you're a little you know
immature and and kind of explain
something that's maybe obious they just
P into their audience yeah so I don't I
don't necessarily mind that so much but
maybe it'll it'll be more grading on me
uh as I go alone in the game but so far
five or six hours in I am thoroughly
enjoying Spider-Man 2o I really am no
doubt Lord King this is the one I've
been waiting for because obviously you
are a huge Spider-Man fam you you are
our resident lore when it comes down to
the comics on what's authentic what's
accurate you know Spiderman 2018 you I
believe you had his game of the year you
you dressed up you called your shot you
said it was going to do whatever it it
did it so I got to know I very I know
you are passionate about this
game let me put the cam you I'm still
here so I don't think I'm gone I'll
still check
you well well first first mhm Go kid uh
adct uh this is for you oh we bended the
knee oh the knee has been bet y'all I
can't remember what the BET was oh
because it didn't come out on
PlayStation 4 right right he's a man of
his word he's a man of his word you go
um you got your knees no doubt salute
all right so um that's the second pair
of knees I oh well you know um next year
it'll come out on PlayStation 4 so
I King is Right 8 8% of the time 8
that's I said 98% 98 right Spidey yes 98
um for all you frauds out there day one
I got this not the
remaster day one PlayStation
4 by the way this Peter Parker is the
better Peter Parker that other
dude throw that guy away you mean about
the you mean you mean the actor the the
the face model we got happy with what
happened the face the face his neck is
stiff his face is ugly I don't like this
dude I don't like him this is this is
Peter Parker he's here he's there in
this version do not get the remaster
that other dude is an impostor he look
like he he he up to no good his neck is
wrong everything's wrong with that dude
I think they up I think they updated it
like if you if you haven't connected to
the internet you might be able to play
it like that but I think they just
updated if you update it and play
without the patches yo yo what Toby mire
I don't want I don't want that dude
straight Tom Holland right there Tom
Holland excuse me Tom holl he's not even
Tom Holland he's he's in between yeah
yeah he's somebody else uh this one dope
dope um day one soon as it came out I
was there miles let's
go same thing with this one day one soon
as it came out I'm there uh I saw the
the the the bugs and the glitches and
the stuff online and I was like I was
just like I hope it's not that hope it's
not that I I don't care so when I was
going to work got up like around 2:00 in
the morning put my joint to download
left my my PlayStation on left came back
home started playing at like around
11:00 uh that day everybody's asking me
did you play or whatever and I had like
put out a little uh
PSA on Twitter about um just keep the
same energy you know with Starfield I
see I see all these people talking about
uh you know um oh he got he got little
bugs here or there it's not a big thing
it's it's 10 uh you know hey every game
has
bugs okay when it was
Starfield it was Microsoft needs to
worry about quality control Microsoft
needs their mismanaging everything Todd
Howard needed to hold this game back um
and I played Starfield and I came across
one bug that was the bug where uh uh the
girl I was with I think was s yeah she
was on the table she was floating
yeah and I was like
yo how how the hell do I get her to stop
floating and and I and I just um I had
went up to space and came back down she
was still
floating and I just kicked off my team
and then when I got it back she was she
was no more float you said it back to
Constellation right yeah so um all right
all right cool that was the one bu and I
and I play that game you know I play it
at my Pace yeah I'm not playing it at as
you know some but you got a lot of hours
star yeah but it's just you know I'm I'm
loving every bit of I didn't even finish
the game yet uh so but I'm doing things
in it every every day I try to do
something all right so Spider-Man let's
go get to Spider-Man as soon as I'm I'm
playing I'm super happy about it because
I'm a Marvel head and I I take these
games the
J okay
um what he eat don't make me blink um so
I I take these games as comic books
right so each comic book is a new
chapter into something else the DLC for
Spider-Man one was the best the story
was the best the game was I didn't I I
can't even say I I ran into any bugs in
the first one can't even say I ran any
bugs in in Miles m Top Notch I'm talking
about Triple A this this is when they
talk about bangers when when you have
these dudes talking about bangers not
the dudes that's trying to land on gas
planets and talk about why can't I land
on a gas
planet you messing like how stupid can
you be like how bro anyway all right
yeah right yeah we know who we talk
about right um land on a gas planet
dummy um stop shooting on a Sunday
continue pow pow pow pow he's down um
so I play uh Spider-Man 2 and I'm so
happy first it's like this first mission
after we do this the big thing with
miles but I was noticing little things
prompts yeah right I go to hit the
prompt it a hit it ain't doing nothing
I'm like y i press the button though I'm
like okay uh do this bring up your
camera to take pictures uh I have to
manually go into my menu to pull up the
camera because my swipe wasn't working
yeah so I'm like okay that's that's a
little bit of an inconvenience right all
right okay
cool um
then it was this this point where I was
trying to fight somebody and he was
stuck in the floor oh and I can hear him
I mean he's shooting at me he's shooting
at me but I can't shoot at him and I can
throw boxes but it ain't G to get him
and he down there talking mad crap yeah
Spider-Man I'll kill you like if you
don't get out that
dirt
so I had to re go
back reload the checkpoint come back in
and my son was with me my son said Daddy
get him first because he like to hide in
the dirt yo your son try to help you
avoid the glitch yo he's like yeah yeah
cuz he was sitting there cuz he you know
he heard about the glitches all day um
so I got the guy and that that that
saved it right yeah it's it's you so
trying to act like he's the the start of
the glitch he's the king of glitches
he's the guy that's the
culprit so I I have encountered four
glitches and four glitches that were and
I'm not talking about clipping I'm not
talking about uh some other stuff that
goes on like running through cars or
running through people I'm not talking
about that I'm talking about stuff that
make me say damn I was on a good road
now I gotta reset or I Gotta Die to
start this over game progression I agree
and I'm
like how come none of these reviewers
talking about
this I don't want none of y'all talking
that ACG
talk he the only one that got the pass
he put it out first he who who who who
smelt it dealt it he's he's the one who
put it out first he get the pass you
other dudes trying to jump on the bottom
of that tweet talk about yeah um yeah
you know I heard about that too and I I
I didn't no no no okay you not get the
pass bro like your fandom is at an
alltime
high you trying to save these dudes from
burning you trying to run in the burn
building and trying to save them I gotta
save my baby I want to know how like a
game gets worse after the day one pass
like I know how that's when your
company's in turmoil when they on fire
oh my Lord when they on fire
we going I've been yelling this forever
when are we going to look over at them
and say they're not the same guys I will
give you that this is very surprising as
the cops go by I agree with you um that
is very surprising that they're known
for polish and to your point the pre
yeah I know you're holding up the old
Spider-Man these two games ain't got
these issues I agree I agree I I I am
surprised now In fairness I know yall
hate when I do corporate C but In
fairness it seemed that that the the
viewers may have played the pre-day one
patch I don't care about that I don't
care about you saw I don't believe you
right because especially when somebody
says if it get anything less than a
nine